creating a new world block-by-block
minecraft is an echo of what dundee
wants a video game redesigning
landscapes developed in a place longing
for the same powers behind you again
dubbed the yes city in the 2014 Scottish
independence referendum this gaming
capital is expectant once more I think
Dundee the vote that you saw and Dundee
reflects that I would look at nature of
the population here the fact that we do
feel I a bit different even in Scotland
you know we feel we're on the cusp of
something quite special and we don't
want that to be that opportunity to be
missed
chris says dundies part of a global
gaming industry often paid in dollars
euros and Japanese yen but the city's
come a long way from its history of jute
mills and famous jams of the 19th
century famous in fact for the three.js
Jam jute and journalism DC Thompson is a
major employer publishers of the Beano
and dandy creative industry is in fact
an integral part of the identity here
its outward looks perhaps given
confidence to people like Louis to now
want something different we just opened
a business a couple of months ago we are
about to have another baby welcome that
and so for the future for Scotland's
future I'd like to be given the choice
that we can exercise the right to to
decide what we want for our future
historically working-class Dundee still
home to some of the country's most
deprived areas with a pervasive
generational divide growing for those
like Allan a staunch unionist the
antagonism of a future referendum is
feared the last time was really nasty
though a lot of physical in
freaking them what is it about Dundee
that makes it double yesterday probably
our hardcore labor lefty background for
decades Lieber was you can elect a tree
stump in Dundee on the Labor ticket an
Alsatian dog would have sealed into the
tootsie rolls and know it's all a sin
people everywhere is SFE for the modern
dandy the way a heads is yet unclear how
this city will look in a decade depends
on its people
Adelle Robinson Sky News Dundee